서울 적 아파트 가격이 최고가 대비
반토막 평균 가격으로 보면 4년
전으로
돌아갔습니다 부동산원 11월 전국
주택가격 동 조사에 따르며 이른바
영까지 끌어모은
2030세대가 격을 게됩니다에
전가격면서 보증금을 해 찾는 서울
지역 세입자가 역대 최고치를
[음악]
기록했습니다 저기 아가씨 퇴근하나
봐 아네 내가 이음을 다 줄테니까
사무실 한번만 들렸다 가자 응 아
근데 제가 지금 퇴근이 아니라
출근이라서
가자 하이엔드 되게 고급 집이야
아가씨 이거 봐봐 아가씨
[음악]
아가씨 이게 말이 돼요이
어제야네 어제 세상에 술을 왜 이렇게
먹었어 어 캐 아 키씨 아 주서 좀
들어봐요 빨리 집가야지 베이 한번 더
마시고 아우 나는 집에 갈 거예요
다리에 힘 정 주지 마요 무거워
죽겠어요가 무거워요 나
가벼운데 오 왔다 왔다 왔
조용해 좋아한다고 말했다고 예 몇
번을 계속
얘기하던데
근데 대리님 꼭 결혼하지 않냐 응
다음 달에 다음달 결혼하는 남자한테
고백하면 못 쩌 자는 거야 어쩌자는
거야 회사 사람들이 자기 얘기하는 거
알까요 쟤는 쟤도 진짜 바보다 바보
예 바보요 사랑밖에 모르는
바보
여 죽었다었네 진짜
말라까 왜 여기 겨울에 모기 있어
모기는 잡을 수라도 있지 아 그 자기
사무실 가서 좀 찍어요 왜 여기 와서
물을 하고
있어 그 저기 그 두 분 내일 아침에
뭐 좀 같이 보러 다니실 건데 저희가
사실은요 부신 데부터 해서 여기서
자리 잡은지 한 30년 됐어요 손님
스타일만 딱 봐도 어떤집 원하시는지
바로
나와요 전세라 그랬죠 월세인데요 쪽도
월세라 그랬는데 제가
전세 전세든 월세든 조절하면 다
가능해요 거기서
거기에요
그러면은 집 보실 때 제일 중요하게
보시는 부분이 있다면 제가 좀 사정이
있어가지고 빠르면 빠를수록 좋을 것
같습니다 남자 분은요 한 달 뒤쯤
이요 아 사장님 뭐 집 볼 때
중요하게 보는게 뭔지 물어보시
운동하는 거
좋아하세요 참 동네 참 정겹다
그죠 내가 젊었을 때 우리 군대에
있을 때 26사단 있을 때 청소하기
편한 방 어때요 그 요즘같이 바쁜
시대 그 청소할 시간이 어디어
물티슈를 한번 썩 닦고 끝내야지 그냥
에헤이 참 에헤이 참 그래도 뭐
역세권 만한 곳이
없다 여기까지
10번 어 다 왔어 다 왔어 좀만 더
좀만 더
에이 9분
[음악]
58초 그렇다니까 다 돌아봤어요
아니래 손님들이 너무 전자는 데
괜찮은 거 하나 보여 드리려고 전화
드렸어 아지금 구도 왔다니 어
잠깐만이 구조 잘
빠졌다 사장 여기 얼마예요
어 전세자금 대출 되고
어 오케이 오케이 오케이 예 예 예
알았어 알았어 오케이 오케이 어 이따
다시 전화할게요 전세 자금 대출 되고
구조도 뭐 보시다시피 요새 트렌드로
그냥 쫙 일단 가격은 2억 2천 이런
거 금방 빠진다 잠깐 잠깐 2억
2천에 전세자금 대출까지 그러면 이건
내
[음악]
거야
이건
음명 그래 나도 전세 한번 살아보자
어 월세 아껴서 문화생활도 하고 나름
업그레이드 하는 거야 어 구질구질
했던 과거의 수키야 잘 가라
빠이 두고 봐 나는
서울에 전세 사는
여자님 봤어요
방금
봤어요 어느 한
남자와 한
여자의 아주 아주
행복한
미래를 많이
[음악]
놀랐죠
나도요 우리 둘만의 은밀한
[음악]
추억 그리고
사랑의
결실 만들어
볼까요이
[음악]
집에서이 집
계약할네
젓가락이 아니 그거는 이제 가게에다
직접 말씀을 하셔야 되는 부분이고요
예 마음대로 하시고요 예 그근데 아니
그 어플에 이품 체크하신 거
아니에요여 또 왜 젓가락 달래 아
진짜 동훈아 나 열심히 하잖아 나 나
잘하잖아 어 도대체 어디서 어떻게
잘못한 부분이 내가 있을까 형은
잘못한게 없어 그지 그냥 그 시스템
문제지 야 재밌는 얘기 좀 해 봐
엉아 기분이 굉장히
꿀부대 내가 이번에 방을 좀 보러
갔었는데 맞아요 아 전세 괜찮은게
하나 있더라고 2억 2천 짜리인데
신축 내가이 신축은 또 처음이잖아
근데지 어 얘기해
[음악]
여보세요 사장님 손님들 여기 마음에
드신다 제가 여기가 마음에 들어서
그런데 어떻게 안
될까요 저도 마음에 들어요
아 그 왼손은 왜 나무 다리에서
만난다는 표현이 생각이 나네요 아
그래요 이제 정리가 좀 됐어 보니까
집을 좀 깨끗하게 쓸 뿐이
들어오셨으면
하시네
[음악]
죄송해요 어떡해 어 생긴게 너무
먼저하지 생기 가지고
오케이 오케이 혹시 그거 담배
피우시는 분 있어요
흡연자 어 안 저 기관지가 안 좋아서
어 사장님 혹시 근데 그 전자 담배는
혹시 괜찮나요 아이코스 찐담배 냄새
나는 거 오케이 오케이 혹시 애완
동물 키우는 분 있어요 애완 동물도
안 돼 본 적도 없어요 아 근데
선장님 그 술 먹고 개되는 건 괜찮은
[음악]
거죠 언제 오셨어요 보니까 두 분 다
뭐 비슷비슷 하시니까 오늘 이렇게
하자 뭐 집주인 분도 일찍 들어오시는
걸 원하시고 계시니까 계약금 먼저
넣으신 분이 들어오는 걸로 그 혹시
계약금이 얼마인가요 가계약금 200만
원 하시면 되시고 계좌번호는 1로 아
근데 혹시 제가 지금 금했습니다
200만 원 이금 하셨어요네 벌써
제가 좀 빠릅니다 선님 엄청 빠르시네
안 보였어 안 보이셨죠 저는 기회가
없는 건가요 원래 집이라는게 말이죠
이렇게 주인이 다 따로 있어 수가
있어요 수수하게 생각하지 말라고 우린
계약을 향해 갑시다 가시죠
2,200만 원 입금하시면 되고
계약금 잔금은 언제 금 하세요 어
최대한 빠르게 해드리겠습니다 확인
한번 해 봅시다네 좋습니다 어디
가셨어
손님 뭐 손님 사무실 나봐요 사무실로
이동하시고 손님 나보세요
손님
사무실로
[음악]
있어 이게 무슨
냄새요
[음악]
Oh
하늘에 계신 우리
아버지여 뜻이 하늘에서 이루어진 것
같이 악에서
[음악]
구하소서 아이 다른 부동산에서 자꾸
전화가 오네 다른 거
보여준다고 님이 제복이 엄청
많으시다 아이 뭐 제복 아지야 뭐
아휴 한강 부 아파트들은 떨어지지도
않는다는데 빌러 말고 아파트 살 걸
그랬나 봐 에이 월세가 잘 나오니깐
또 아이고 내 정신지 마 커피도 한잔
안 내왔다 그죠 사장님 여기 우리
사모님도 실차 뭐 있을까요
그니까 집을 넘겨졌다는 거잖아 응 똥
때문에
어 너너 뭐야 뭐 산타클로스 키다리
아저씨야 너 뭐야 너 아니 살다
살다가 진짜 방을 선물로 주는 새끼
내가 또 처음 본다이 새끼야
어 아이고 어서 와요
안녕하세요 아 오셨어 아 여기
인사하세요 여기 세입자분 여기
집주인분
안녕하세요 여기
사모님이
그집 전 입자로 딱 들어오시는 거고
아 잠시만요 내 이거 두고 왔나
이거를
잠깐만 나이가 어떻게 돼요네 아 아니
엄청 어려
보여서 아 아 저 27
살입니다 하는 일은 직장은
다녀요네 다니긴 해요 요즘 같은
시대에 아무한테나 집을 줄 수
없으니까 기분 나빠지 말고 다니는
회사 명암 같은 거 있으면 하나
줄래요 명함이
응 우리 사모님이 워낙
신중하셔야 명암 스캔 받아 놓은 거
있지 않아요 그거 먼저 보내 드리면
되겠네 잠금은 여기다 넣어 주면 돼요
아 그 그
잠금은 이거 원래 주한테 저가
들어가죠 내가 집진 있데 왜 나한테
돈을 안
넣어요 아니 내 통장이 아무것도 안
지킨다는게 말이 되냐고요 그게 내
통장이 돈이 들어와야 되는 거고
근거자료가 되는 거잖아요 저 그게
맞는 건데 이게 전세 자금 대출도
그렇고 잔금도 먼저 이렇게 건축주
먼저 들어가요 그리고 그다음에 이제
은행은 그렇다
치고 잠금은 내 통장에 들어와야 된다
이 말을 하는 거라고요 그리고 나
통장에 들어오면 건축자 테 보내면
되는 거잖아요 아시겠어요 아 일머리가
그렇게 없어요 누굴 봐보 하나이
사람이 아 나 참 내가 이상한 거야
아이 이상한 건 아닌데 사모님 우리가
그런 경우가 잘 없지
싶다 나도요 내 돈 요만큼도 하트로
쓰고 싶은 생각
없어요
입금했습니다 정근
[음악]
3247 3247 차주분 있어요 아
저요 3247 이세요 아 예예 아니
거기도 주차를 하면 내 지금 찾아야
되는데 여기 부동산이면 금방 보고
나가려고 그러는데 아니 아줌마 아발
차 좀
빼주세요네 아
사원님 아
이책 입금됐어요 확인해 봐요 아 선님
잠시만요 잠시만 내 잠깐 확인 잠깐만
할게요 아 예 여보세요 아 예
믿음입니다 예 그 저희 지금 계약
중인데 그 잔금 입금 됐는지 좀 확인
좀 부탁드립니다 예
예 아 이금 떴어요
아 예 예 예 예 예 아 예 예
그러면은 어 기 2만 원을 왜 넣냐
아니 어 아닌데
잠깐만요 저기 사모님 잠시만 이따
다시 전화할게
[박수]
[음악]
사모님 도하 기적이 일어났습니다
한국이 역대급 경우의수를 풀어내고
카타르 월드컵 16강에
진출했습니다 문이
열립니다
회사 잘
돌아왔어요네
아네 뭐 또 힘들 때일수록 동료가
있다는게 그렇게 큰 힘이 되니까
지아입니다 이제 스키
씨 이번 주 말에
뭐해요 출입은 들어가서 꼭 해주
됩니다 사진이나 동영상 촬영 안
되시고요 어 혹시 메모 아이디 어떻게
되세요 저 네이버 sui 27이
땡
[음악]
감사 어
스키시
for
현명한 전세사기 예방법에 대해서
알려드리도록 하겠습니다 우선 첫
번째로 등기 정분 증명서를 꼭
확인하신 다음에 소유자가 누구인지
체크를 하셔야 되고 반드시 전세금도
[음악]
소유자
딱
죄송합니다 다시 하면
되겠네을
해야지
[음악]
m